key
[Musique]
et hop
oh
on a ça
[Musique]
no
muet
bd
non
[Musique]
et
m
[Musique]
lendemain
deux stars après
m
tu as beau temps
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce que
[Musique]
arrêt
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
g
[Musique]
et
merci beaucoup merci à tous vous venez
donc d'entendre notre groupe
winter woods winter ou 12 ans fait ses
quatre copains maximilien baptiste
corentin et figurez vous qu'on s'est
rencontrés dans la rue c'est aussi
simple que ça on était quatre étudiants
fauchés
on aurait envie de boire un coup et on
s'est dit pourquoi pas sortir nos
instruments essayer de récolter quelques
pièces figurez vous que ça a bien
fonctionné
pas parce qu'on a pu financer notre
soirée ça oui mais surtout parce que ça
a bien collé entre nous on a donc décidé
de créer un groupe
il fallait trouver un nom winter woods
ça résume assez bien la philosophie de
notre projet on avait envie d'intégrer
la notion de bois pas uniquement parce
que baptiste est ébéniste
mais parce que le bois quand vous passez
votre main dessus vous sentez plein
d'aspérités du relief
c'est vraiment quelque chose qu'on
voulait retrouver au sein de notre
musique
le relief l'authentic vers une musique
organique et vivante
du coup il fallait aussi réfléchir au
processus créatif qui allait animer
notre projet et c'est en fait le coeur
même de la raison pour laquelle on fait
de la musique créée c'est un outil
fantastique
la musique permet vraiment de
photographier des instants vous avez
vous traversé une période de votre vie
soit parfois très joyeuse soit parfois
très compliqué pour santé plein de
choses comme un tourbillon d'émotions
tout ça s'atténue avec le temps la
musique à cette force de pouvoir
photographier cet instant et de le
rendre intemporel pour ça on est très
fiers que ce soit notre chanson gengis
comines qui ouvre aujourd'hui le ted
parce que j'espère que vous comme moi
vous sentez que le changement arrive
sommes des jeunes face à un monde comme
le disait aline tantôt en crise on a des
enjeux des responsabilités qui sont
colossales je suis absolument convaincu
que demain sera meilleur
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]